pour apporter un peu d'exotisme dans
l'hiver montréalais
ce papillon a fait un long voyage en
avion
chaque année de février à avril stéphane
le tirant fait une trentaine d'allers
retours entre le jardin botanique
l'insectarium et dorval
les papillons vivent pas si longtemps
d'une semaine à un mois donc on doit
renouveler constamment les papillons
donc chaque semaine on soit des colis de
chrysalide qui on en reçoit de
différents pays pour avoir une belle
variété c'est lui qui orchestre les
commandes qui viennent des quatre coins
du monde
ça arrive fréquemment que jma ramant
certains ados kahlo à 11 ans à minuit
les chrysalides des papillons en
gestation ne peuvent pas trop attendre
juste un papier d'aluminium avec des
petits trous c'est fait pour que les
chrysalides plus respirer mais aussi
pour les protéger du froid
hier c'était en colis en provenance des
philippines
aujourd'hui mario bonneau va déballer
les 400 chrysalide du costa rica qui ont
passé quatre jours dans la boîte inclus
en transit et inspection à miami
littéralement et bijoux c'est vraiment
splendide belles boucles d'oreilles de
voir ce que d'étaples être avéré que
c'est vraiment trippant le donc moi je
me sens privilégié ouais bien excité
aussi suggère de les les accrocher puis
aussi voir combien vont réussir à donner
en pâture sur le louvre est dans la
nature le taux de réussite de leur faux
pas qui on est très très faible
c'est moins de 10% de ses 4 6 4 6 %
chaque lit si on réussit à voir août 80
% de d'émergence donc on sait très fort
comme si peu de colle chaude un morceau
de carton plat ça gigote oui on est plus
un
vous avez vous bouger c'est dans la
pouponnière que les chrysalides
deviennent papillon deux fois par jour
c'est la récolte soleil il donne tout un
spectacle
puis le transfert dans la grande serre
le monarque il une des vedettes
et bonne nouvelle pour les monarques
migrateurs on peut espérer en voir plus
l'été prochain il était près du seuil
d'extinction mais ont connu une hausse
fulgurante de 144 % l'an dernier
les milieux des années 90 où il y avait
plus d'un milliard de monarque ok elle
est descendue à moins de 100 millions
hélas avec l'augmentation qu'on a eue
l'année passée en étant de 5 250
millions $ pour la première fois les
billets sont en prévente
on veut ainsi mieux répartir le flot de
visiteurs jusqu'au 28 avril après quoi
les derniers papillons seront
recueillies au filet une enveloppe un
papillon ses cordes et dans des boîtes
avec un espace qu ils seront expédiés
vivant vers le musée canadien de la
nature à ottawa
ici à nourrice despatie radio canada
montréal